[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today our
question today comes from Corey in
Tennessee I've been a quote a vocational
instructor at my current job for 20
years they aren't interested in learning
anything on any level the students are
very disrespectful the bad behavior is
encouraged by decision makers I have
also worked at my church with young
people for 19 plus years and I'm
honestly burned out on kids I need to
work but I don't have much debt but I do
have some I just don't want to earn pay
being disrespected on a daily basis and
seeing the toxic Behavior encouraged the
state of Tennessee my job in the state
of Tennessee requires retirement at 25
years excuse me I messed that up the my
state of Tennessee job for retirement is
25 years at 55 years of age or 30 years
of service I'll only be 49 if I stay for
30 years so I don't know how that will
pay out I think I can do better and
start making more money I'm con
currently thinking about pursuing CDLs
to start a driving career what do you
think should I quit my job I couldn't
even get through it because you need to
leave my man
now don't leave without moving into
something but there's no question you're
not in an environment that you have any
control over to actually change uh when
you when you put yourself in an
environment like this that is very
institutionalized and very systemic as
it relates to government leadership
you're not going to be able to change it
so quit banging your head against the
wall I love the idea of moving into
something else let's get qualified for
it and then let's move on because
financially you don't have the margin
and you've got debt you got to pay off
so let's stay in the roll let's get a
couple of part-time gigs if you can do
it if nothing else just to get some
relief from this current day job that's
just beating the snot out of you yeah
but let's move on to something else and
as quickly as possible
so um quit working with youth at the
church today
yeah
that's easy
that's a non that's a no-brainer
they don't need you because you don't
like it
and they can tell yeah and so can the
kids right yeah so it's good for the
kids for you to quit it's good for you
to quit so that that's one incremental
thing it sounds like you actually like
teaching
so I don't know where CDL came from that
sounds like something flew in Midnight
cable TV or something I don't know that
just sounds bizarre you know what it is
it's like sitting behind the Escape
that's right so I don't have to talk to
young people I don't have to talk to
anybody yeah and I'm in a big truck so
nobody can make me mad you know I mean
it's oh my God no I don't think that's
um I don't think that's a career choice
I think that's just your running away
sure and so
um
yeah I think you need to go take Ken
Coleman's career assessment and figure
out I mean it's like 20 or 30 at our
website at Ramsay Solutions okay figure
out some things you need to do and then
you need to you don't need to run from
something you need to move to something
and the CDL is just you running from
something but you have um
you have five weeks to I'm making this
up to select something to start moving
towards and then I'm gonna give you four
months to move towards it so you need to
be out of the church teaching business
by the end of the day today
and you need to be out of the state
teaching business by the end of the year
yeah yeah and you don't give yourself
some deadlines you'll bathe in the
sewage yes because you're comfortable
with what you know versus what you don't
know and that's all I know and I think
Dave you make a very good point there
there was a season of life where you
were excited about being an instructor
and a guide and uh to the extent that
you might be able to move to another
state agency where you are in training
uh that is still the heart of
instruction of guiding people and so
look in you know where you've got
relationships because this is a
government job certainly kick the tires
on that as long as you're training
instructing I enjoy teaching you do
absolutely but I refuse at my at early
in my career I refuse but I really
refuse now to be trying to teach someone
that's there against their will correct
so if someone wants me to come speak to
their organization and the people in
their organization are there against
their will I'm not willing to do that
um or I'm not willing to go speak to a
bunch of people that vehemently disagree
with me and my job is to be there to
piss everybody off no thank you I've got
other things to do I'm there I want to
talk to people that I can actually help
that's right and move the needle for so
you know that that's just human nature
you don't want to wait bang your head
against the wall it's just silly so yeah
you you need to be teaching probably I
think you'll find that if you take the
assessment yep thank you I think you'll
probably see the result of influence
which is very people focused work and uh
probably see communication there uh
instruction you'll see those themes so
uh go get that ramseysolutions.com is
the get clear assessment and for anybody
thinking about that how do I take those
results and put it into a real time job
very simple you take that purpose
statement which is a wonderful gift that
we give you there as a result of all of
your other detailed reports and you
begin to say this is what a job
description looks like where I am on
purpose I am there doing something that
makes a lot of sense to me because I'm
I'm good at it I enjoy it and the
results fire me up that's what you're
looking for and in this case he wants to
engage with humans who want to learn
something in order to be able to do
something I've got a friend who's a
classroom teacher and got burn up
burnout and beat up and was done with it
and um so she went on to another career
and and you know some corporate training
and things where she actually enjoyed it
but instead of doing the ministry thing
at church she is teaching
um the uh U.S
citizenship course oh fantastic and it
she said is the most inspiring I'm sure
and I mean these people know more about
American history than we do sadly are
these folks trying to become citizens
and uh man it's she said their English
is in a second language almost the same
course you know you're teaching that way
Oh my he she said it's just she's so
excited to go down and and by the way
they don't even pay her she goes for
free
you know it's just incredible so yeah
that's a sad thing or Ministry thing and
um so yeah if you get in the right
situation where people are begging to
learn oh and you're a teacher oh it's
just about the most fun you can ever
have it's just chocolate chip cookies
straight out of the other man it reminds
me of the first time Stacy and I taught
Financial Peace University we were in
Atlanta and we had several young couples
we were all working with and they were
struggling they said hey you know this
Dave Ramsey guy says he's like yeah I
worked for him and they said will you
teach us and we were like of course and
so we put a class together in the first
week we walked in the room and we could
see the light in their eyes they were
like help us sitting on the edge of
their seat and that and we didn't even
teach we just press play on the on the
tape and you did the teaching but that's
the opposite of Corey he's not got
people sitting on the edge of their seat
unless they're trying to leave the room
right that's right yeah so that's tough
stuff tough stuff that is very hard but
very good advice by the way in pivoting
right to okay wait a second I love
instructing and so it's not instruction
I need to get rid of it is changing my
environment where I'm instructing and
who I'm instructor but I learned this
from you listening to you coach on the
Coleman show
um it's an amazing number of times that
someone thinks they hate what they do
and they've because they've confused
what they hate where they do it and who
they do it with yeah they're doing the
right thing in the wrong place with the
wrong people yeah absolutely oh for sure
toxic people for sure toxic environment
toxic culture but doing the right thing
and then they go well I'm burnt out on
teaching no you're not no no burnout on
hanging out with stupid people that's
right well you know Dave I I shared this
yesterday on the show we have a shortage
of teachers Public School teachers in
America this is a big time problem and
the reason is is because the environment
has gotten so awful that these teachers
who signed up to instruct to guide the
future generation they're walking away
well they don't want to deal with all
the woke stuff that's they were they
want to teach history that's right I
didn't want to teach gender reform they
don't want to get screamed at when they
give a kid a bad grade because the
parent can't handle it yeah and there's
a lot of junk going teachers unions no
no help that's correct and the
helicopter parents are coming in here it
is I don't know Ken did you know this do
you know where snowflakes come from
though helicopters